es ist soweit computer sind tatsächlich
in der lage verbrecher zu finden
zwar nicht im vorhinein wie bei minority
report obwohl mayer aber immerhin nach
der tat beziehungsweise den taten in den
usa bleibt zurzeit tatsächlich jeder
zweite mord umgekehrt wie gar nicht hat
sich ein amerikanischer journalist
gedacht und hat einen algorithmus
konzipiert mit dem sich ungeklärte
verbrechen aufklären lassen mit erfolg
und in deutschland da werden algorithmen
benutzt sogar um verbrechen
vorherzusagen also da werden wir dann
doch beim 1
wie das genau funktioniert und was sein
algorithmus alles über verbrecher weiß
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen und zum schluss habe
ich noch eine ganz besondere
überraschung
in deutschland wird das predictive
policing genannt gemeint ist damit
polizeiarbeit die auf computer
vorhersagen basiert minority report
lässt grüßen in bayern baden-württemberg
beispielsweise laufen dazu pilotprojekt
eine software in deutschland entwickelt
sagt voraus wo einbrecher demnächst zu
schlagen werden das ganze basiert auf
der annahme dass täter und täterinnen
natürlich auch nach mustern arbeiten
dass sie beispielsweise orte bevorzugen
an denen das gute fluchtmöglichkeiten
gibt oder aber dass sie in erfolgreiche
gebiete zurückkehren und wieder
zuschlagen genau das sagt die software
voraus und wenn sie sich zumindest 70
sicher ist schlägt sie alarm dann werden
polizisten und natürlich polizistinnen
an diesen ort geschickt vielleicht ist
das die polizeiarbeit der zukunft in den
usa hat sich der amerikanische
journalist thomas hahn und eigenständig
eine ähnliche software gebastelt
angestachelt und motiviert wurde er
durch den sogenannten zettel river
killer dieser serienmörder hat 48 frauen
auf dem gewissen
ein foto des killers an seinem
schreibtisch erinnert ihn immer wieder
an die dringlichkeit seiner idee mit
hilfe eines algorithmus verbrecher jagen
eigentlich war thomas tage auf
polizeireporter und hat auch immer mal
wieder aus dem waisenhaus berichtet aber
die zahlreichen ungeklärten morde in den
usa die ließ ihm einfach keine ruhe und
somit finger tatsächlich an das größte
mordfall archiv der usa anzulegen mehr
als 750.000 mordfälle hat er hier
archiviert und übertrumpfte damit sogar
das
bei dessen archiviert tatsächlich 27.000
mordfälle weniger zählen ihn zukommt in
den usa gibt es keine nationalen
datenbanken dagegen stehen etwa 220.000
ungelöste mordfälle dazu haar auf in
einem interview
die einzige möglichkeit herauszufinden
dass zwei morde zusammenhängen ist dass
sich zwei ermittler zufällig in der
kantine treffen und ihre fälle
vergleichen
seine konkrete idee die entwicklung
einer software die gemeinsamkeiten der
verbrechen identifiziert wie wurde das
opfer getötet wurde das verbrechen
gegangen und um welche opfer handelt es
sich alle infos zu den morden der
letzten drei jahrzehnte wurden ins
archiv aufgenommen und das
computerprogramm machte sich an die
arbeit nach möglichen gemeinsamkeiten
der unterschiedlichen mordfälle zu
suchen und es hat tatsächlich geklappt
der software war beispielsweise
aufgefallen dass es in indianer 15
ungeklärte todesfälle gab und zwar mit
frappierenden gemeinsamkeiten die opfer
allesamt frauen wurden erwürgt und in
verlassenen häusern aufgefunden
doch die polizei dort ignorierte die
hinweise von thomas harloff einen
serienmörder im eigenen bezirk undenkbar
doch der ehemalige journalist war
hartnäckig zudem passierten weitere
sieben morde auch diese opfer wurden
erwürgt erst dann handelte die polizei
mittlerweile sitzt der killer hinter
gittern und hat weitere sechs morde
gestanden
das fatale auch diese morde waren bis
dahin von der polizei nicht als morde
erkannt worden
tatsächlich ein großes problem in den
usa 5000 menschen töten dort pro jahr
ohne dass sie dafür bestraft werden und
die aufklärungsquote sinkt sogar in
deutschland sieht die statistik etwas
anders aus zumindest sagen dass die
offiziellen zahlen der polizei demnach
werden ihr mehr als 90 prozent der morde
aufgeklärt
es gibt allerdings auch kritiker die
diese hohe erfolgsquote in frage stellen
das wissen von hamburgs datenbank zu
serien killern jedenfalls ist gigantisch
die morde werden demnach zehnmal
häufiger von männern als von frauen
begangen die täter sind meistens nicht
sehr intelligent und die opfer sind in
mehr als 70 prozent der fälle weiblich
und zwischen 20 und 50 jahren alt
spannend auch die folgenden effects
rechtshänder fliehen meistens in die
linke richtung werfen spuren die sie
belasten könnten allerdings eher nach
rechts thomas adolph hat es also
tatsächlich geschafft computern
beizubringen serienmörder zu enttarnen
daran beteiligt ist auch seine
gemeinnützige organisation mörder
accountability project mpp mittlerweile
hat der ehemalige journalist ein
gewisses standing einen neuen hinweise
an die polizei in cleveland nahm die
behörden tatsächlich sehr ernst und
haben eine sondereinheit abgestellt denn
thomas adolph hat mit hilfe seiner
datenbank indizien entdeckt dass dort
womöglich ein serienkiller sein unwesen
treibt und mittlerweile bereits 60
frauen auf dem gewissen hat und der
algorithmus kann noch mehr er hat eine
wirklich verblüffende erkenntnisse ans
tageslicht gebracht demnach starten
viele zukünftige mörder ihre karriere
als brandstifter thomas adolph sucht
also mittlerweile auch nach
brandstiftern und er ist nicht mehr
allein mittlerweile haben sich
zahlreiche hobbydetektive wagen
geschlossen
die seine datenbank nutzen um
serienmörder zu entfernen und das ist
genau das was haben doch wollte zitate
wir wollen uns dass wir eine online
version zur verfügung stellen können wir
hoffen sehr dass polizei detektive und
auch die öffentlichkeit des nutzen
werden um potenzielle gefahren zu
identifizieren wer und jetzt gibt's das
ganz besonderes zehn jahre clixoom und
da habe ich mir gesagt
dieses jahr könnte auf jeden fall mal
persönlich zu mir kontakt aufnehmen und
zwar alle
und das wird gehen mit whatsapp meldet
euch bei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr
als erste von den neuesten videos
garantiert und ihr könnt direkt mit mir
chatten und themenvorschläge machen oder
andere ideen vorschlagen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken probiert es mal aus und ja
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
klicken
hast du ihn bedrohen die erde jederzeit
und auch nicht vergessen natürlich zu
abonnieren und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran
ich freue mich auf zahlreiche
anmeldungen